certainties in life death and taxes but
it's taken this government to callously
unite the two the Ministry of Justice
has revealed many families who once paid
a flat fee of either 155 or 215 pounds
to gain probate the legal control of the
deceased estate will now be hit with
dizzying rises in the amount they must
fork out in some cases the charges will
rocket to six thousand pounds look I
accept if I'm implying to get my hands
on a sari for control of and the state
such as great dykes it's likely to be
worth quite a bit more than that of a
broadcaster and journalist formerly on
the son who has to hold down three jobs
just to pay the milk bill but having to
pay 2500 pounds for probate on an estate
value between half a million and a
million pounds considering the value of
properties in cities such as London and
areas like the home counters and
Cheshire was plain wrong taxes have been
paid all the time these estates have
been built up this is akin to modern-day
grave robbing so your objection is not
to the inheritance tax your objection is
to having to pay more for poem 8 yes I'm
glad you asked me that probate is a fee
you have to pay to take legal control to
the estate of someone who's died at the
moment it cost as I say between a
hundred and fifty two hundred and
fifteen pounds the government wants to
replace this from April with a sliding
scale of fees linked to the estate's
value ranging from 250 to a maximum six
thousand pounds under the proposed new
system
it states value between 1.6 million and
two million will pay five thousand those
between 1 million and 1.6 million will
pay four thousand etc they're raising
the threshold at which you start paying
fees from five thousand to fifty
thousand pounds in a sense it's great it
should be staggered and what do you get
for six thousand pounds it would and
you've probably paid a citizen to do it
yeah so I don't disagree with you at all
I'm right but I think it's a wider
discussion about inheritance tax right
because there are a lot of accountants
out there who can make sure you're never
paying you inheritance tax yeah and
inevitably richer people yet that
because they can afford they can afford
the accountants advice and there are
companies going around just trying to
give that advice
so I think there's a being discussed
about inheritance tax but this is just a
see the government did this I know this
is the real budget they throw all this
cash out and then things like that it's
my issue with this I think that we
should have a broader conversation about
taxation and making sure it's
progressive and you're right because
500,000 pounds buys you in some cases a
to been that in not even affluent parts
of London or other know where he lives
but if you look at this particular this
particular increase the government's
saying is gonna be used to fund the
Ministry of Justice and specifically the
court service which is chronically
underfunded I mean I'm Ministry of
Justice is at breaking point
run courts so that people who are
low-income and needs gets caught don't
have to travel hundreds of miles which
is already happening some cases but my
issue is we need to look at we need to
raise revenue to fund crucial parts of
public service which are falling apart
but what I don't like about this as I
feel like this government's doing it
myself there's no transparency there's
no step back and saying what revenue we
need to raise to make this country
functional and how do we go about it in
a way that doesn't hit poor people more
and instead they're just not looking at
the bigger picture introducing things
dishonestly by stealth so then you can't
really I I listen to the budget coverage
I had no idea about this and that's what
made this country pay an inordinate
amount of tax anyway you know we pay tax
on every penny we pay tax on our
pensions we pay that national in shows
car tax poll tax council tax we're taxed
up to the hilt and this government rakes
in a fortune from this you know one
hundred and seventy five billion a year
from income tax hundred and thirty five
billion a year from from hang on from
that and 125 from national insurance
that's enough from the people of this
country and it is this is gonna hit
that's why you can pick up a hospital
and nobody's gonna ask you for your
credit card we're taxed enough you want
the services without paying the tax you
can't have them you either have to
either have a good my arm you either
have good services or you and you have
to pay for them or you paid someone to
execute we look on this one not this one
just took some ear dancing Trevor
you're a fair-minded Souls I'm a bit
puzzled about it's not you know I'm
thinking my daughters who might be
watching this who you know regularly
look on Rightmove to see what the cost
of the tent that I live in in the back
of somebody else's garden yeah it's
gonna bring them where they when they
push me under a bus in London the
average in the borough where I live the
average house price is 1 million pounds
to be honest 6 grand for probate which
you can borrow from the bank if it feels
too well that's a different thing
I just think to be honest I'm surprised
it's so low that surely surely what you
should be charging these tax on the
estate not just I think it's next point
they suddenly you suddenly go so bad and
you're paying this
now if the estate is I don't know 20
million you're still only paying 6 right
there - intact I agree with her let's
make it let's make it more progressive
I'm for moving from income tax to wealth
taxes and for all of that but I I wonder
why we would make a fuss about people
who are about two hundred hundreds of
thousands pounds in the bank
why would make a fuss about them having
to cost me 200 quid and today it cost me
two grand I have no idea why it's not
transparent and you know I I think the
bigger issue for me is that we kind of
have the worst of both worlds we have
high taxation and often massively
underfunded breaking public services you
know I think if we felt like we were
getting a good value from our public
services we would maybe be more
comfortable the idea of paying I think
this will stop people making wills and
what it means is people might give start
in life and that's gonna call that's
gonna make well actually I think what's
actually going to happen in more people
gonna get away without without paying
what the government tells us is this
quote from Justice Minister Lucy Fraser
is that by raising the estate value
threshold from five thousand pounds to
50 thousand pounds we will be lifting
around 25,000 estates
annually out of fees altogether for
those who do pay around 80% of a state
will pay 750
or less this new bandit fee model
represents a fair and more progressive
way to pay for probate services compared
to the current flat fee and reflects our
commitment to protecting access to
justice by ensuring we have a properly
funded and resourced court system and I
think actually that moves more in the
direction of what you want which is
which is change ignores middle income
people in cities who are the jams that
Teresa may talk just about managing
you've got a small house just big enough
your family you pay high income tax you
pay high council tax you are now being
here with a big increase in something
like a super 8 I'm super excited I'm not
gonna be paying but it is not the house
it's not the person who's dead isn't
paying it their best son or daughter
might be a doctor who lives in a big
house we all people know and they know
for quite a long time that they are
going to get this asset and I think but
I must say I think it's a bit odd to get
bit of all the things that you could be
worried about this is not one that would
work I suspect there's two lows but
surely the discussion should be about
inheritance tax not about the trivial
bits around the side really because they
call they should be about inheritance
tax and when you say interaction you
know this is I mean inheritance tax by
and large most people's wealth when
they've died is a house yes and which if
you happen to be like in live in London
or certain parts of the country your
house that you bought for 50 grand is
now worth a million litres but the next
generation is faced with these
completely unaffordable house prices
they're relying on that inheritance to
be able to start themselves it's all
wait no one can afford to buy a house
without some help from somewhere it's
it's such an unfair market I'm spending
the money now they look